sometimes we wish we could be young
again and then we think about it and we
realize that it is not the best idea
today we're going to take you back to
your teenage years
think about your high school your first
love first date homework studying tons
of exams and of course high school proms
you feel awkward yet never miss another
video by subscribing to our Channel and
don't forget to hit that thumbs up
button now join us as we take a look at
10 of the most Awkward prom pictures
ever the overprotective dad every father
hates seeing their little girl growing
up and they hate it even more when they
start dating
we understand parents don't like it when
their children grow up one day they're
just babies barely saying their first
words and then their date is taking them
to prom can you see why this picture
might be just a little bit embarrassing
for these teens this dad is clearly
showing how he feels about his daughter
going to the prom
we love overprotective dads and this one
surely looks like he's made his child
awkward on quite a few occasions do you
think this picture was staged or did the
kids really not know what the dad was
doing behind them it looks like this dad
is ready for prom but he's also ready to
protect his daughter from anything or
anyone high five for protective dad's
this dad probably just wants what's best
for his daughter and he's definitely not
afraid to show it high five for the
overprotective dad we just hope this was
all taken with a bit of sense of humor
would you be embarrassed if your dad did
anything like this let us know in the
comments below the little boy staring in
the background alright we're not quite
sure how we're supposed to feel looking
at this picture but it definitely makes
us feel just a little bit uncomfortable
have you ever had a situation like this
when someone was just staring at you
while you were taking a photo it's
probably even more embarrassing if they
actually appear on the photo you've
taken these two girls seem to be just
casually posing for a photo for their
prom well the young man in the
background can't really believe what
he's seeing
we wonder what he's thinking about did
the girls know he was behind them or did
they find out after they checked the
photo not only is this young man
photobombing the picture he looks like
he's really studying whatever he's
looking at he's definitely dressed for
the occasion and looks like he could be
a family member what do you think he's
looking at on a scale of one to ten how
awkward does this look we're giving it a
solid 7 give this video a thumbs up if
this photo made you feel just a little
bit cringy the guy without a prom date
every class has a funny guy who finds a
way to make a group photo look even
funnier it can be because they're making
a funny face or pulling another joke
well we appreciate their sense of humor
we're not quite sure what to think about
our next photo it looks perfectly normal
right just some high school students
taking a prom picture right but what do
you think that blurred part on the left
is any guesses
if you've guessed a pineapple then you
get a thousand points we're not sure why
someone would hold a random pineapple in
a prom photo but this guy certainly wins
the funniest prom picture award why
pineapple if you look at the picture
closely you'll see that everyone in the
photo has a prom date could it be that
he's going to prom with a pineapple
high-five for being creative and
laughing it off kid his orange bowtie
does compliment him very well and while
he might have been the goofy one on the
photo he definitely does have style if
you ever need a prom date who knows
asking the celebrity might turn out to
be the best prom night ever guys dressed
as a rainbow if you ever need a group
prom dress idea don't worry we found the
perfect thing for you it looks like the
weather prom fashion is still going
strong
check out these seven dudes we wonder
whose idea it was to get dressed in
rainbow colors but for some reason the
boy in purple looks like the mastermind
behind this project but we have so many
questions about this photo we just don't
know what to do with them who made their
outfits are they carrying water guns to
actually make a rainbow why didn't
purple get the memo that his toy needs
to be the same color as his outfit
but most importantly why did this happen
we're sensing this high school might
have challenged kids to the most
creative prom dress and we hope these
kids won what do their prom dates look
like we have so many questions which
rainbow guy is your favorite we really
like the one in yellow if you're looking
for rainbow prom dresses to match with
these guys you're in for a treat
they're beautiful check out this cute
rainbow prom dress
that's definitely ready to rock the
night away we hope these boys had an
amazing time at their prom
they definitely deserved it Adam
Levine's prom if you feel embarrassed
about your own prom experience this
should make you feel better everyone
goes through it including Adam Levine oh
yeah the heart-melting maroon 5 singer
who probably gets quite a few marriage
proposals each year had his very own
prom experience people are classifying
as cringy so before Adam Levine got hot
and tatted up he was dressed in a white
tuxedo and had a ghost-like complexion
or maybe it was just the 90s camera
settings and he wasn't alone his dates
outfit was matching his as was her skin
they both looked like they just saw a
ghost or two don't worry we have more of
Adam Levine's prom photos here's one
with his friends it looks like Adams
didn't get the memo about wearing a
black tuxedo these prom photos were
taken before the big dance at the
Brentwood School in Los Angeles
somewhere around 1996 do you think Adam
knew at the time that he was going to be
a big-time celebrity a lead singer of a
popular band and crowned as People
magazine's sexiest man alive we bet
celebrities are more embarrassed about
prom photos and other pictures from
their teenage hood than anyone else
inappropriate prom photo kids are pretty
hilarious but sometimes things just turn
a little bit inappropriate whether they
realize it or not but this prom photo
really takes it to the next level and
we're pretty sure the dad from the first
photo on our list would have something
to say about this dress codes at a prom
aren't anything new and schools have
different rules on how to make sure
teenagers dress age-appropriate girls
often aren't allowed to reveal their
back they can't wear and
things see-through and sleeveless
dresses have to have a shawl or a jacket
but is there a rule for prom photos
although we're very impressed with the
fluffy rug in the setup of this
photoshoot we think this prom picture is
definitely taking it just a little bit
too far and what is the guy holding on
to whatever it is this picture is just a
bit inappropriate for teenagers and we
can totally understand overprotective
parents who wouldn't approve on a scale
of 1 to 10 we give this awkward photo an
8 we think it's just slightly more
awkward than the young man in the
background which photo will get the
number 10 you'll have to keep on
watching to find out whether prom
fashion this one will make you do a
couple of double takes before you're
able to take it all in the detail is
just far too amazing and we can tell
these kids put some serious input into
their outfits whether it is odd looking
or not we are completely in love with
this prom fashion these two really got
some style even though they might be
just a little bit odd our wonderful lady
on the left is sporting an amazing
rainbow dress an interesting looking bag
and green heels with flowers springing
from the front she also has a yellow
umbrella with a smiley face the
gentleman went for the blue silver and
yellow color combination and a slightly
bigger than usual bowtie rainbows
lightning and an umbrella we sense a
theme here what do you think their
outfits are made of we're pretty sure
it's duct tape did they design them
themselves if so it must have taken them
a long time they certainly deserve the
award for the most creative prom outfits
we have ever seen
what is solutely perfect we call this
photo don't rain on my prom well done
kids
funny dad there are overprotective dads
out there but there are also dads with
millions of jokes and those who just
love looking for ways to embarrass their
children the first thing that pops into
mind when looking at this photo is o-m-g
do you see it the man in the background
that's showing far too much skin his
smile is definitely telling us he's got
an amazing sense of humor and this
probably wasn't the first time he
decided to photobomb his daughter his
poor daughter probably
didn't even realize what was happening
but we'd bet that whoever took the photo
was laughing in the background but we
also feel for this young girl and hope
the photographer made her take another
photo without the awkward dad in the
background
Fairplay dad this was a really good one
family members who are trying to
embarrass you at your special events are
hilarious and we love them you might not
realize it as a teenager but when you
look back at your memories pictures like
these will make you giggle the most
high-five for embarrassing family
members what was the worst way your
family embarrassed view at a public
event let us know in the comments below
unfortunate cats the world wide web is
full of surprises and sometimes you find
pictures that just aren't explainable
just when you think you've seen it all
you stumble upon something that makes
you feel a little bit uncomfortable it's
exactly what's happening in this photo
and it will definitely give you a level
of embarrassment we weren't able to find
who the couple in this picture was but
maybe that's for the best we can't tell
if this was intentionally done and if
these kids just happen to have funny
parents who love to have a good laugh
but we appreciate this odd prom picture
maybe it's the cat that definitely looks
like it doesn't want to be there or
their faces that definitely look like
they don't want to be there but the
cherry on top is the tiger rug in the
background these kids either don't look
happy they're going to prom or they hate
that their parents made them take this
picture who knows this might just be an
unfortunate photo and I thought nothing
of the tiger rug in the background we're
really not sure how to feel about this
but this definitely fits our top 10 list
of most Awkward prom pictures ever
friends
can you guess who are the winners of the
most Awkward prom pictures ever it's the
beloved friends gang sure it might be
fictional but you have to admit watching
that whole prom episode made you feel
awkward and we bet you cringed more than
once the hair the fashion the
look and we're not just talking about
the young Ross Geller not many people
could pull off an uncomfortable 80s prom
as well as the cast of friends there
were many awkward scenes but one of our
favorites is the photo of Monica and
Rachel looking at Monica's date Ross who
was casually playing on his keyboards in
the background paid no attention to the
fact that his beloved Rachel didn't have
a date for the prom and if you've seen
that episode you know it gets even more
unpleasant as the story goes on we also
love this picture of Ross and Rachel the
puffy blue dress the mustache the cool
80s look man it just can't get any more
cringy than that prom isn't always the
most amazing time of your life sometimes
it can be just a bit embarrassing but
hey it's okay
everyone has their embarrassing moments
do you have an embarrassing moment from
your prom let us know in the comments
below don't forget to subscribe to the
things if you like this video check out
10 prom dresses girls regretted wearing
thanks for watching and bye bye
[Music]